okay so this is princess monster wife
and this is a really good episode like
this is like and next to the one the the
Christmas one with the build-up to the
end and stuff like this might be my
favorite honestly I really liked it I
think this will go over the story real
fast this is a Ice King is going and
he's literally taking his favorite parts
from each Prince says they likes and you
know which makes no sense compared to
the last ones where it's like people
could die and stuff it's like oh you
just parts from them and they're fine
kind of semi gruesome but I guess since
they don't show the blood I guess it's
okay weird well the first time when I
saw it when I see lumpy Space Princess
when they're all standing outside of
Finn and Jake's and she's got the two
bags of uh yes first it's from a
distance and I'm like oh my god is that
her guts yeah but even like with
bubblegum like your tongue yeah
but they they always walk their line and
I guess somehow they get away with it um
but it schools I don't mind um and it
turns out it was the Ice King what would
be Ice Cube forgets or it doesn't
realize they're talking about that oh
you mean these parts I stole yeah which
is a great reveal because I actually
didn't think he did it I thought that'd
be too obvious and then the fact that he
is it's like oh that makes a joke you
know funnier so infinite Jacob knocked
out and it's just him spending time with
this princess monster wife and her
trying to feel normal but she's so
repulsive that apparently Finn and Jake
can't look at her without fainting and
they see some nasty looking creatures no
sorry I think that makes it pretty for
you but it's just the Ice King spending
time with her and trying to convince her
that she's normal I love it when they
sent me watch the TV of the normal
people doing nothing see where the are
more like that were adorable uh
he goes to all the Penguins named
Gunther and Gunther and Gunder and good
T in it that's brilliant that's a
brilliant joke and yeah ventually Finn
and Jake wake up and they tried to they
try to stop him and she fears out what
she is that she's all the best parts and
that she's a combination of parts but
she likes being the ice King's wife and
likes belonging and feeling normal so so
she go she clearly takes herself apart
puts all the parts back mostly in the
right place I don't know how lumpy Space
Princess and turtle princess are gonna
and then just the cloak I guess what was
it yeah went back goes back to the Ice
King and says though my parts are
scattered I'll always be your wife and
he turns into a dumbbell joke you know
which is fun of you but I with again
with the the Christmas one where you
felt both really torn apart seeing all
the stuff he's gone through but you're
also laughing cuz it's the the build-up
to this joke yeah it's like you'll never
be mentioned again yeah I know I mean
it's like but it's I what that was all
at the end of like this very very funny
build-up and then here's this payoff
yeah even if it is really tragic and
really dramatic uh with this one it was
sort of like I'm really watching us it's
the first time outside of that where I
really felt like you're always kind of
laughing at how pathetic he is and I
always see the tragedy but I just really
friggin fell for him in this one and I
felt for that princess monster wife too
and I love the animation is great so
many good things that I loved the hot
dog princess at the beginning I must hug
you climbing up a man and he pushes her
down I mean that's you build a struggle
of her trying to climb up I love those
out of those ice buffalo or whatever
that you could see the organs inside of
I love that you see the cat
too late now they're um and yeah I just
legitimately I legitimately fell for the
two of them even though it's all the
voices of the other princesses it's
somehow foreign this identity and I I
took it up I thought was great it was
very Frankenstein obviously but it was
sure it took it kind of to a different
level like I said having to be sort of
different people and having the parts
scatter at the end and how does that
form of consciousness I don't know but
you could just kind of get away with it
I I loved it I I thought was really
great so that's nothing me target so and
in a way like hearing you react when we
were watching and you're like oh my god
I really feel bad for him it's like
vindication I've been telling you sons
of bitches it's not feel bad for him
it's that it was I'm always kind of
laughing with it too it's like I feel
bad that's also funny this even though
there's funny moments it's like I'll let
you be like she surely I'm really it's
like it's like my heart really goes out
to this guy because he it's like for the
first time he's genuinely happy and
content ain't prepared all this stuff
for her and he just he wants to he does
want to help someone he just wants to
sorta do it his way he wants to feel
needed you know it's it's just nice like
I said cuz that's just kind of how I
felt about him from the first like
couple episodes in season when I was
like I get it I get it I get it and it
was like well everybody thinks he's a
joke and and he's a bumbling fool and it
it was nice this was an episode where
it's like okay now you see where I'm
coming from now you see why I love him
so much it was really sweet
and I mean he's just so sweet I love the
scene where they're doing the dishes
dishes he's like can you dry you wash
and I'll dry and this is how we do we
take our turns and then
Morrow you'll do that and wood will
switch off and you know just like a well
it was like this dirty peanut it's our
kid I'll show you what trick it's real
neat I mean it's like so sweet what and
though in the way the way he the Tom Tom
Kenny the way he the way he acts in this
I mean especially it's like it is it is
kind of funny but like when he's really
saying like these legitimate heartfelt
things to where it's like you buy it you
only buy it and I think he and all these
actors do such a good job finding that
serve balance between what's really
funny and really kind of heartbreaking
in traffic and in this one like I said I
mean Ice King to me I get with the
exception of the Christmas episode where
I think it was sort of like an extreme
half-and-half and that's more just the
placement of it of that reveal with this
it wasn't as much I was gonna have fun
II have tragic like you know I
legitimately feel the tragedy of him in
this one like more than a hour episode
because he just feels he seems so happy
and he seems like he finally has what he
wanted that what he wants really is to
give something and he wants to teach and
yet they say he wants to feel needed and
I think when you have a character that's
constantly trying to take things it's
such a contrast to no they want to feel
that you want to give they don't want to
take but in order to do that they feel
that's like where the you know the poor
psyche of the character comes in but
really what they're looking for is this
they're just going about it the wrong
way
Raven even the little song he did when
they but you could feel that he was
content Hey look you're absolutely right
you can feel it's very heartfelt you can
feel it he's content it's not just like
this Lola it could have come off as some
crazy man living this bizarre fantasy
cos hi clearly she's this crazy monster
looking thing but the way he does it
you're absolutely right you feel like
this is a normal couple he is really and
truly you buy a thousand percent he's
absolute
in love with her no matter what she
looks like it's not I'm getting at my
fault look my buddy
it's your brother my brother yeah we can
do without Jason we're gonna break it
yes I said a damn thing yeah yeah
God so but I liked you I also liked the
idea which is funny because it's a very
even though monster white you can tell
why she has her issues I'm a monster and
I'm ugly I'm unlovable and the same way
it's kind of sneaky because that's how a
lot of women are anyway in general and I
thought that was really neat that you
could kind of relate and eventually
after like the first reveal of oh god
that's what the hell happened to all
those knives you know I kind of felt at
least for me I felt for her a lot not is
like oh ha ha ha this monster thing
realized that she's a monster it's like
oh god no I hear you honey I have days
like that you know it's this idea of
every woman feels that way they may not
look like that monster but they feel
like that monster and when he's you know
and the Ice King says to her you know
like no you're beautiful I love you the
way you are and it's like oh my gosh
it's just a whole nother level of really
great great sweetness you know but he
did the he made her do the little
fashion show or whatever and I looked at
Jason I'm like you would absolutely do
something stupid like that to make me
feel better that's just you know that's
why you got that runway door weird Oh
anyway it was for you I do want Rock
down it like this but yeah but no it's
and the other thing I like to is that
you know he you sort of think to
yourself oh he always wants like just
the hot looking thing or whatever I
don't even know how many of them are of
age or whatever but you know he wants
like you know he wants the prize the
trophy prize and stuff like that here I
mean here's something that's just
clearly doesn't look good I mean I said
Finn and Jake pass out looking at her
but he doesn't care it's everything that
like you
to him it's are like mathematically this
makes sense because well that's all of
them so it's are like the perfect bride
and he just sees even though like
everyone else excited says oh that's
ugly and it's obviously that's not a
very good-looking creation he just sees
like just this you know beautiful loving
thing and he just adores her and it's
it's a it shows a side to us or to him
that I was like oh like I didn't know
that was legitimately in there like you
know like he can learn if he like no no
it's okay and I think that's that's the
interesting part like I said that's more
that he wants to he wants to feel needed
and he wants to give more than he just
wants the trophy prize or or he's work
it out through you know whatever his
mental issues with you know his past
real wife you know that doesn't have to
be a knockout it could just be someone
that needs him so what do you have to
say so in other words he's not looking
for love he's just looking for someone
that needs him so into lord over what he
can do for them oh he needs
companionship someone who needs him as
much as he needs them okay look
lightweight this way it's I think he
thinks he needs and he thinks he has
that but he's still taking it from tons
of other people you know it's still a
diabolical plan of course online cuz
online never lies they you can always
look up these things where it says you
know the ideal woman quote unquote where
they say like polls were taken these are
the the blank has to pass slips so we
took those blankets the best diets we
took those they literally piece together
this like monstrosity of a woman that is
supposedly the best features from all of
the women and that's what Ice King said
he said I took my favorite parts from
the princesses show kind of but that's
the thing to him it's not that it's this
monstrosity like you said and I don't
even think he's notices it because these
are his favorite parts from each one of
these so he look seems like my favorite
part of bubblegum uh my favorite turtle
and he's that wacko no I don't think
once you want some that you know you can
sit there and control no I know no you
were so wrong well no I mean is so wrong
no no this is training her to do this to
do the dishes no he's not that bad I
don't know don't worry we'll let that
soak you'll learn that later no no no no
no yeah okay okay wait that's why if he
was training her just to be like his you
know what it's important it or whatever
and stuff why would he take her to fly
through the caverns and play the token
okay why would they get teary-eyed
okay let me put it this way a bus
abusive husband do they start out
abusive no no they have the trick of
luring in the women being nice and
everything they get married and then
boom all sudden they start changing it's
a slow progress it's a brutal sorry slow
progression Wow King is totally abusive
well a few episodes going throughout
three penguins that we don't even know
if they were dead or nuts
okay well huh fs:i something else though
- it's not all that saying like this is
a hey this is a legit relationship why
could they live together it's a no this
is still scary parts from other people
except for the poor other you know
princesses ya know and that's no that's
what I like to I like to find the
creation realized this was right
that's very Frankenstein like the crazy
realized it and when it put things right
you even if it meant giving up herself
oh I'm just gonna vent I'm just more or
less joking around with the whole him
looking for say that or do that because
you know stolen yeah there in the first
on the job no what I really like is last
episode was a werewolf this episode I
know but this episode was Frankenstein
it's monster yeah I like the fact it and
of course Marceline a vampire they're
hating on a lot of the classic monsters
especially recently and they have
mummies um well kind of mean I'll kind
of looked mummy esque but you know they
haven't I know
artyom zombies of course yeah so like
seeing like an actual Frankenstein's
monster I think it's kind of neat well
and I like that this is the one that
they had because technically you could
do the same kind of setup for the story
with the Ice King you know another
princess or somebody that we with just
some other princess they made up or
something but I like the idea this is
the one where he took all the part yeah
different creation and that's one he
legitimately has like a real
relationship we know why though because
it had slime princess his bum that's
what made it all come together
I can't formed a butt while saying that
slime princess hisses yeah you
contribute so much to this one is your
dark brother still talk now you've said
like yeah he's a jerk yes my princess is
body no I mean this thing has gone on
for who knows how long it's probably
longer than the episode no I liked it it
was it was fun it was interesting I
don't know if I felt the tragedy in a
sense or you know the heart-wrenching or
whatever that you guys did but it was
nice to see in them show the Ice King
that no he isn't just looking for a hot
piece of ass he's just looking for
companionship you know he has it in his
penguins but it's not enough he wants
someone that his female that he can
actually talk to and he can learn with
and teach it was nice and I mean I I
remember when first time I saw it he was
throwing the pictures underneath and
he's like they're gonna look and he's
like I took this from this and you know
that I was expecting the monster to be
all pissed off that's what I thought was
given to him like oh my god you took me
from here and she's she opens up and
she's like so you love me even though
I'm Olly you know I don't have these
other parties yeah I like that they did
that too and he's like well yeah of
course I'm like that's really nice and
then of course I do like the whole you
know Finn and Jake with their you know
the mirrors and all that's time they
pass out yeah
honestly woman where that's happened to
me with honestly it's those things her I
don't know if they could even help it
because I mean they no no they are legit
like they always want to help they want
to do what's right but as if they see if
they pass out it's like just their
senses camp like oh they cannot get past
their sensitive which I sort of like
over that necessarily being like mean
mean they're not saying anything it's
just literally they can't stand looking
at everything which is like somebody I
really enjoyed is that this is not a
Finn and Jacob let's say I like that do
not save the day there's almost nothing
that they do it was we had a problem
with you know lumpy Space Princess
she cannot carry an episode yeah um I
have a problem with tree trunks I don't
think tree trunks can carry an episode
or hold an entire episode around her and
that's why that's your opinion but this
shows that Ice King can actually carry
an entire episode as a character what is
Jake our very secondary hasn't he kinda
he kind of has but this is one word it
was pretty much all him yeah yeah
they're out of it and that's I think
that's kind of neat that there are minor
characters that can carry the show no no
definitely well and he is probably one
of the more like really fascinating was
he's certainly a me I get a feeling like
with the writers like this has got to be
the most fun character to write for yeah
I mean you can so easily make him look
pathetic but tragic at the same time and
that's just a beautiful combo and
writers love to have fun with that cuz
everything you're doing is making you
laughing at a cry but same time yeah and
the only thing I'll say that's on top of
my mind is when they're sitting there
and they're watching what the normal
family on TV which I liked about the
title card yeah and they're just doing
nothing and they're just sitting on the
couch but they look normal and normal
like that and it just reminds younger
and like I think everybody goes
especially through school and stuff like
that you go through it's like oh do I
fit in and my this level popularity or
this level popular is somewhere in
between and where am i and stuff like
that and a lot of times I think we do
kind of look to like especially if
you're younger you look to the media to
say you know tell
what's popular tell me what's normal
tell me how I can fit in and I don't
know I just that scenario just showed
sort of the nonsense that it is that
it's like if why would you want to be
what's on TV that feel like everything
else and it's normal it doesn't stand
out you know what makes you unique is
what makes you unique why would you want
to be normal like everyone else yeah you
know if other people can't see it that's
their problem
you know that's sort of what I like that
the Ice King was doing with her too so
it's uh I like to I put a lot of good
stuff in there a lot of good elements
good animation good good writing good
commentary like a lot of different areas
I'm yet I loved I thought it was just
great uh speaking of the old TV shows
one thing I remember is being younger
and of course trying to compare this
that the other thing to it and then one
day it hit me it's like no one has a
bedroom that big if you look at the
bedrooms and all of the TV shows the
bedrooms are the size of our living room
and oh yeah well there's studio sets its
huge and then it hit me it's like no one
I'm all of my friends that I've ever
hung out with no one has a bedroom that
big okay I have just found that line
between reality the size of the bedroom
that was really where it hit me and you
know everything else nice sized living
room and all that stuff yeah but like
bedrooms where like they can have
literally a concert in their bedroom I'm
like I don't know anyone that can do
that you know so knows me it's a nice
feeling when you wake up and it's like
oh like this doesn't matter yeah you
know I you know I was trying so hard to
be like this on TV it's like oh that
doesn't matter if as I get older this
makes you really boring and
uninteresting the stuff that makes me
really freaking weird it's what makes me
interesting and fun and different and
people are like be true yeah it's like
I'll remember you I won't remember
gigantic bedroom kids or like whatever
that's like bedroom
yes but like you know it's like all
these kids you were trying to be like
you'll usually forget yours later yeah
you know that's what's so funny it's
like the ones you do remember are the
oddballs in the winners than the ones
that weren't doing what everyone else
was doing so so screw society yeah fuck
the power always bring them TV don't
watch TV anyone all these videos I'm
fine with that
see you bring up my I mean our
popularity this whole video is just a
plan to get a stop watching TV and watch
nothing but us yes this is working I
think you need a hug are you fucking my
wife Hey